it's so crazy not knowing what's getting
tattooed to my body right now we hear
about to get tattoos I have no idea what
she's picked for me and vice versa it's
a little bit nerve-racking it's
tormenting we get in Mary we do we are
engaged and we've been together for more
than years we've known each other since
high school for about 11 years
we both packed up our lives and shipped
over here from Sydney so that took a
great deal of trust I feel like this is
the ultimate trust test before the way
I'm still nervous that this is like
nothing in comparison her body and
suddenly I have this weird authority
over it which is really uncomfortable to
be honest I'm hoping I really love this
tattoo because I'm gonna be walking down
the aisle but this tattoo hey Mike for
Shelley nice to meet you how I picking
something for your girlfriend what are
you thinking I'm actually thinking of
this leaf the Gumley from back home in
Australia we're really hung over just
drawing on bits of garden that was a
leaf that I drew oh that's cool yeah she
was like I'm keeping it forever and she
was like stoked on this one she actually
lost it later that day her housemate put
it in the bin the next morning I woke up
and I could hear all this stuff outside
the back of the house and she was
actually emptying like a full garbage
bin and she found it and kept her and
she still has it was a little cool
reminder of finding her in the trash I
actually have two ideas as well
depending on what is viable for the time
frame I found this picture of a
pomegranate every time I see them I
think of her but I also think of my
culture and heritage what do you think
let's take a look at the other one
so when Rochelle and I first started
dating
really and this was one of the leaves we
take a peek at that and my housemates
actually threw that leaf away so I had
to rummage in the bin did you really
find it it was covered in all sorts of
things here I like it it's gum leaf yeah
it's a gum leaf and where's shelleyan I
know my leaves yeah I thought maybe the
lines here would be a little bit to find
to have a feeling we might be able to
come up with a simpler version of this
mm-hmm that way it can't be done mm-hmm
I think we should go pomegranate in
simple yeah complicated just like her
the splash of bread as well is like pie
ah yes right your love for bridled
passion she's so gonna break up with me
so what are you looking to get done on
her I think would be really cool to have
by grace through faith tattooed on her
okay it comes from the Bible
it just encapsulate s-- her journey went
through some very difficult times in our
life but her faith in Christ is what
kept her so strong she loves like super
minimalistic cursive fonts so I was
thinking of getting for the good but in
a nice modern clean font and I'd like to
make the tea kind of like a cross yeah I
feel like he's just such a warrior his
favorite verses Romans 8:28 and it's all
things work together for the good you
know things happen for a reason I think
that's just something he lives by and I
feel confident that it's something he
will love ready to go oh wait as well
wait can we sketch it out no no we just
freehand it on we don't we don't use
distance or anything
No yes okay
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay baby s-sir but it goes down that
side why LA County health code violation
Oh
cheerleaders got to stay in the stands I
just want to hold her hand man
[Music]
we know yeah
you breathe - one look
for the game I love me really yeah
that's my favorite bible verse all
things happen for the game this verse
has kept me through everything that I've
been through I held on to this truth
especially when it came to who my future
wife would be and I just had this
incredible amount of faith and he led me
to you which is the greatest blessing I
love you it says by grace through faith
in the most pretty cursive writing
I was says with like little Cris of
writing like this I love you
[Music]
200 your granite is really round like a
crab well it is it is oh yeah
holy crap I didn't even think of that
that's kind of like you because it's
like a little bit gory and I'm the
painter and mine is like a hot like its
anatomical this one represents you to me
fits really well I did good guys I felt
like a whole bunch of zigzagging at one
point like an octopus I was gonna get
you yet amazing that's so amazing
silly stuff I will keep me forever now
yeah and I said to her I was like this
life is staying with me forever at the
time and now it really is
[Music]
you
[Music]